-Michael, how are you doing?
-I'm doing great.
How are you, Seth?
-I'm doing very well.
We've talked to a lot of peopl
over the last six months
who have been self-isolating
but you are our first
home-confinement guest.
And I want to talk a lot
about the cont--
-I'm breaking
new grounds for you.
-You are.
You're a trailblazer.
I want to talk about
the book's content,
but I'm also sort of fascinate
by the process,
because you did write this boo
in prison.
Was that a conducive place
to the writing process?
And, more importantly,
did your fellow inmates know
you were working on a book
-So, the answer
to both questions is, yes.
It was conducive.
I was working at
the sewer treatment plant.
And there was a lot of
free time, believe it or not
so I would put myself
into the electric room
that had a small desk,
and, on a yellow pad,
I would begin to write.
And at the end of each day
I would sit down with a grou
of the -- my friends, inmates,
like Tony Meatballs
and Andy Cucumbers
and Stevie and Herbie
and a whole group of guys,
and we would get together
in a cube.
Usually it was mine, cube 28
And they would come
for a reading,
and I would read them
different parts of the boo
that I was working on,
and it was just something
that we did to pass our time
-Do please,
when you speak to him,
give Tony Meatballs my best.
And I would also want to ask -
I know you were worried that a
manuscript like this, obviously,
a lot of people wanted
to get their hands on it.
You were worried
that it would leak.
Like, how do you protect
something like that
when you're basically, you know,
confined to a place
where you're not in charge
of your own materials, really?
-You're not in charge of
anything, to be honest with you.
So, there was a situation
that took place.
I used to keep the manuscrip
under my mattress.
And, unfortunately,
there was a little incident,
and I knew I was going
to be taken to the SHU --
the solitary confinement,
the segregated housing unit.
And I was concerned
that the CO's,
most of whom
are Trump supporters,
that somebody would get
ahold of it, see what it was
and then pass it along
to somebody.
And, so, it was
the day before Passover.
And outside was the rabbi.
He had the fire pit.
And normally you burn
the chametz, the bread,
the night before.
And I took my manuscript,
and I dropped it into the
fire pit to everybody's anger,
but I did it anyway
because I had to get rid
of the manuscript.
-I bet you're probably
one of the few people
that has used Passover
for that purpose, Michael.
A trailblazer in another way
-Go, Passover. [ Laughs ]
-So, Michael, we --
Our show interacted with you
back in the early days
of the Trump campaign
because we were in conversations
about having him on as a guest
And one of the things
that you reached out --
-Seth, can you believe --
Seth, can you believe
that was five years ago?
-I truly can't.
I can't decide if it feels lik
yesterday or 1,000 years ago
though, because time
is folding in on itself.
-For me,
it doesn't seem the same.
Yeah, for me,
A lot's happened for me
over five years.
-Yeah, exactly. You probably
didn't picture yourself
working in
a sewage treatment unit.
-Well, I went from
one crap house to another.
-Very well-played.
-Thank you.
-By the way, I'm shocked to hear
that working there
you have a lot of downtime
I guess that's one
of the upsides
of working
in a sewage treatment unit
So -- But I remember
you reached out.
One of the preconditions
you had about --
Or one of Donald Trump's
preconditions was that
I would have to apologize
for jokes I made
at the White House
Correspondents' Dinner.
And I'm wondering if,
in your time working for him
you often had to reach out
on behalf of his ego
when speaking on his behalf.
-On a regular basis.
It was unfortunately
on a very regular basis.
And thank you for at least
acknowledging that it was hi
directing me to do it,
not me deciding to do it.
-You -- You know,
it's interesting you say that,
as well, because in the book
to your credit,
you do admit to taking
a very active role.
You were not just
a passive bystander.
You were, yes, following orders,
but you knew they were
the wrong thing to do,
and you did them anyway.
You speak about Trump supporters
and the sort of whole Trum
world as being like a cult
You're obviously
not in that cult anymore,
but you sort of exited the cul
because of the legal situation
you were in.
Had that broken differently,
had you not had
those legal troubles,
do you think it's possible
you would still be
in the Trump cult?
-It's very possible.
I can't give you
the answer to that
because I can only speak
from fact.
And the fact of the matter i
I was, for an interesting term
excommunicated
from the Trump cult,
not on my own volition,
as you stated,
whether it was
the legal proceeding
or Trump and his cronies
deciding that I should be
the fall guy.
But it's very possible
that I would still have been
in that cult.
I am --
It's the one thankful thin
that I am for everything
that has happened.
It's given me an ability
to amend with my wife,
my daughter, my son,
and actually the country,
to make amends.
-When we come back after
the break, I do want to talk
about some of the things
that you sort of admit
to having a great amount
of regret for now.
But I did -- I did appreciat
that you admit to the fact
you did not have
a "come to Jesus" moment here.
You were sort of kicked out,
and it was then
that you reflected back.
And it is nice to read a boo
where there aren't
a ton of excuses.
And when we come back, we're
going to talk more about that.
We'll be right back
with more from Michael Cohen